تعشينا وحدود الساعه 11 كل مين بغرفته
العشاء والاخير وسبحان الله هو اخر ما جمع
مصطفى بوالدته واخوته وابنائهم
قبل ان يدفنهم الزلزال تحت ركان هذه
المباني
اطفالي كل ساعه
حركن باجري ما اقدر اوصل للضيقة
لما نحركهم صيح بابا زهير يتاخر بالرد علي
هون انا خوف
قول يا رب دخيلك بدي ما يكون الولد مات
معي نداء المكلومين هنا وجد مجيبه
يلا يلا روح يلا مريم
بنتي مريم
هاي طلعت اول الشي ثم زهير
وايلاف وزوجه مصطفى
وهو اخيرا
هاي الاصوات وانا تحت لحظه شفنا الضوء
عرفت انه كتب لنا عمر جديد
من تحت الانقاض فلديه قصه حياه كتبت من
جديد ليرويها بعضها اقرب الى الخير
اسامه هو الاخر فقد زوجته
واربعه من
اطفالهم سوا
هاي هي اولادها وحطيت لها بنت بحضنه يعني
مثل ما كانت حطيت اياهم تفرج
لم يبقى لاسامه سواء ابنه احمد صوري من
رحلوا
في كل صوره غصه
هي واختها رحمه
هي الصور بين التوثيق لاستذكار الاحباب
والالم على من رحلوا
هاي عيلتي كامله
هاي ندى ورحمه وام وعبير ونواف ضلينا انا
واحمد لحالنا هدول كله راحوا
عمر الحوراني الجزيره الشماليه سوريا